what if i told you the reason why
america became america like the greatest
country in the world that a lot of
people would say
it worked so well for them but they've
gotten away from it and it's one of the
biggest mistakes america is making today
and it's a mistake many are making in
their families and their companies and
if you're making this mistake yourself
it could be hurting your business and by
the way as i make this argument to you
if it makes sense give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel so let me
get right into it i believe what made
america great
is
the younger next generation coming up
when they look up at a hero they said
man
i want to be like george washington one
day i want to be like lincoln i want to
be like rockefeller i want to be like
andrew carnegie i want to be like
benjamin franklin i want to be the next
innovative creator building a business i
want to be a disrupter growing up right
and we were great at making the right
people heroes our hero making machine
was unbelievable and today we have
forgotten who the real heroes are and we
are now building up complainers as
heroes so think about this when you were
growing up as a kid who was your mom's
hero who was your mom's heroic who did
your mom look up to what did she say oh
my gosh baby that's such a great leader
who was that person who was your dad's
hero think about it and when your mom
and dad talked about who their heroes
were how did that impact you didn't you
kind of internally were like wow man i
would love to see my if i become like
that man one day that woman one day
maybe my mom's gonna be like my son is
not my hero my daughter's not my hero
and i'm gonna get confirmation from my
parents i'm gonna hear those magical
words honey i'm so proud of you i wanna
hear those words right so the hero
making machine was this
what if today america is turning
complainers into heroes i'm like oh my
god what a great complainer you know
what i want to be when i grow up i want
to be a great complainer why because all
america and the mainstream media is
putting on tv as complainers the more i
complain the more eyeballs i get did you
see that girl's video went viral you
know why the video went viral she was
professionally complaining and bitching
about everybody and rich people are
greedy and these people suck and those
guys suck that's the game plan i'm going
to use and we completely lost
perspective of who the real hero was do
you remember back in the days we had the
lifestyle of the rich and famous why do
we want to watch that lifestyle because
we kind of wanted to have a good
lifestyle do you remember rappers and
hip-hop artists nice cars and nice toys
i wouldn't mind having a lifestyle like
that do you remember real estate moguls
i wouldn't mind having my dreams become
a reality today that's not the case
today's those guys are the villains
today anybody that elon musk is such a
villain what a villain he is you know
bezos what a villain he is all these
guys are not becoming villains so we're
confused so what does this have to do
with you
in your office if you're running a
company or if you got a family wife
husband kids be very careful who you
turn into your hero of the office in
your company whoever your number one you
paint
salesperson executive
you say let me tell you guys johnny over
here the best in the company if you say
he's the best in the company and he's
also the biggest complainer all your
other guys want to be like johnny when
they grow up because he when he goes to
lunch he teaches everybody how to
complain and he's undermining you in a
very creative way that you're not even
aware of it and it's just other people
are saying if this guy says he's the
hero i gotta also start undermining i
gotta also become a complainer and they
duplicate it the same goes with your
kids versus if you uplift the right
number one the right hero with the right
attitude with the right effort with the
right loyalty with the right all of that
stuff you're like oh this is what you
call a good citizen i want to be like
this person my dad build up men
of strong character based on values and
principles and because i wanted to make
my dad hero i wanted to be the man that
my dad painted as a man of character so
that's the argument on america today we
went from being the best hero making
machine country in the world
to now being the best villain making
machine in the world and turning
complainers into heroes if this argument
makes sense to you give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel and on top
of that with this video here the video i
want to recommend to you it's a video i
did five years ago titled 10 signs you
won't be rich you may want to consider
watching this video if you've never seen
it click over here to watch it take care
everybody bye bye bye bye
[Music]